we survived two world wars we've
survived a pandemic we've survived a
number of recessions and we cut our
cloth accordingly we don't think the
business has been through such a tough
time
welcome to the Denture Bakery I'm the
Fourth Generation member of the family
business
um I have a daughter who's just started
as a fifth generation Baker and we've
got a bill here signed by my grandfather
um from
1931. davenshire Bakery is one of the
many businesses fighting for survival in
the current economic climate retail
sales plummeted in 2022 as a cost of
living crisis and Sky High inflation
took its toll this forced many companies
to go into bankruptcy in the largest
number of insolvencies since the 2008
financial crisis in December 2022
insolvencies were 32 percent higher than
a year earlier and 76 percent higher
than in 2019 an economists say this is
just the beginning of a wave of
insolvencies about to hit the UK when we
speak to insolvency practitioners
they're telling us they're having an
increasing number of calls from
businesses which have reached the point
where they're going to have to close
down and that's an issue because small
and medium businesses are really the
lifelong of the UK economy small and
medium-sized businesses account for 99.9
of the businesses in the UK they employ
three and five workers and about half of
the turnover in the private sector wage
costs
um ingredient costs
the energy costs they're the three main
areas it's about
ensuring that we're profitable or if not
profitable certainly
breaking even
energy bills in the UK have reached
unprecedented levels
very high energy use that's a big
problem how much do you spend on energy
oh it's gone up to about 8 000 a month
and how much did you spend last year
that was it was between three and four
thousand a month
so that's doubled it's doubled yeah we
are adapting to the to the energy costs
we've got a brand new oven that we put
in last year here we have units here
that that are holding chocolate and and
icing so again they're switched off at
weekends now yeah so we've switched off
a big part of our deep freezing
Refrigeration now the energy costs
towards the end of 2022 harmed the
business contributing to the 25 of the
revenue they said they lost last year a
lot of businesses have received help
with their energy bills over the last
few months that support will start to
fall away leaving businesses responsible
for more of their own bills going
forwards if there isn't any other help
it will be a problem for us we've got a
bit of reserves in in the bank but that
would only last a couple of months
[Music]
milk has gone up by 44 we use for a lot
of milk and cream so the chipped
potatoes that come in that went up 36
flour that's gone up by 23 percent the
baker is navigating a price increase on
raw materials and that's leading to a
bigger question around how much of these
costs can be passed on to Consumers we
had three price increases last year
never never before we had to do that and
we'll be looking at another one raising
prices comes with a competitive
disadvantage at a time when people are
increasingly policing what they spent so
baked goods like these ones are a
special commodity but then how much can
you put the prices up by our lives are
like three pounds something for the big
Loaves and
when you're going to Tesco's you can buy
it for one pound
[Music]
so we started we started work at UH five
o'clock this morning first Bakers were
in
our biggest cost is is the wages so they
are 50 of our turnover we uh currently
employ 45 people
um pre-pandemic we were
um not far off double that
so we've we're running a far tighter
ship the number of days we open are
reduced
um which has enabled us to employ fewer
people but give them a more secure job
to meet inflation the UK living wage is
going up by 9.7 and that adds to the
increased costs this business will have
to navigate this year on top of
increasing energy bills
while it may not seem like much for a
business which employs a lot of people
that's going to be a real added extra
cost The Squeeze resulting in
insolvencies is Nationwide and it
affects long-standing businesses like
this one that are in many ways the
fabric of the British High Street
yeah there's a lot of um business over
owner fatigue I think the worst case
scenarios over the next 12 months we're
going to see a lot more business
failures it means gaps in the High
Street and it means
um fewer Employers in the UK there is
always room for
um
cutbacks although we think we've we've
hit as many cutbacks as we possibly can
it grinds you down eventually
um and that's probably a lot of the
reason why
um businesses are are closing
um but but I think if you if you embrace
the challenge
then there will be light at the end of
the tunnel
[Music]
thank you